President Trump of course he is abroad
right now did you know that President
Trump arrived in a I thought that means
you're aware of the news that you're
happy he's gone it's a very confusing
signal you gave me President Trump
arrived in England today and he was
greeted by hundreds of angry protesters
now of course it didn't help that Trump
arrived in England wearing a Croatian
soccer jersey that may have music what's
the problem I slowed her Nepal was the
top of the pile and he grabbed it right
he walks off the plane and went like
that and they they got upset they got
very upset while in the UK president
Trump was asked if he was worried about
the protests there and he said this is
quote I think they agree with me on
immigration
ya know Trump has a point many people in
England want him immediately deported
what else is going on this is very
controversial a Republican congressional
candidate follow me on this Republican
congressional candidate sent out
anti-semitic messages in a robocall yeah
of course anti-semites are now furious
that robots are taking their jobs like
that's what I do
[Applause]
that's my impression of an anti-semitic
purchase know what that is let's demand
the founder of Papa John's has resigned
after using a racial slur in a
conference call he resigned yeah people
are calling it the second worst thing
Papa John's founder ever said since I'm
starting a pizza company that was a bad
idea
it's gonna look like pizza it won't
taste like pizza
you